(upbeat music)
- I just texted my parents that I'm going
to go drag racing on
the bridge from Greece.
And then I asked them to remember me well.
(engine roaring)
- Were here today to drag
race some fast expensive cars.
- I'm scared.
As much as I love looking at fast cars
I've never been in one.
And that's kind of terrifying to me.
- It's something I've always wanted to do.
- I love fast things.
I love dangerous things.
I love adrenaline.
- I hope that my screaming
isn't gonna distract them.
I'm gonna be screaming.
(upbeat music)
- This is Andy.
He's my driver for the day.
So how fast will we be going?
- Over 100 miles an hour for sure.
- Do you think the Ferrari
can beat the Nissan?
- That is one of the fastest
cars on the face on the planet.
- That's what I heard.
- This is my driver Riley.
This is a faster car?
- I think it's gonna beat that.
Especially with Andy driving.
So I don't think he's gonna win.
- Oh!
Shit talk, you guys.
I'm ready for this to be over.
- I'm feeling really confident.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah.
- I feel like this would not
be here if there wasn't danger.
(screaming)
- Oh my god!
(laughing)
- Did we live?
I don't even know.
Awe man, Quinta can eat shit.
All that matters is that I won.
- I loved every minute of it.
I now get why people drive fast cars.
That was dope.
- I'd rather buy a nice purse.
- I picked Riley to be
my driver in the Ferrari.
So we're gonna kick some butt.
- We're gonna win.
- I picked Andy to drive me in the GTR.
Because I feel like he
knows what he's doing
and we're gonna get a sure fire win.
Come on man!
I have confidence in you.
- Look at me.
Do I look like I'm fast?
The car goes fast.
- No one's asking you to run anywhere.
- Kendall has no chance.
- They're going down.
(mumbling)
(upbeat music)
(laughing)
- That was exhilarating.
I wanna do it again like seven more times.
I'm addicted.
- How do they do that
sexy get out of the car?
- There is no sexy way
to get out of these cars.
- Uh-uh, not at all.
- It was like being on a roller coaster--
- You have the control over it though.
- Yeah.
- So, we won.
- We're the winners.
- And now we're gonna take on each other.
- In the finals.
Here's the problem though.
Is that we both had Riley as our driver.
Riley.
Why don't you come in here and you tell us
who you'd rather drive.
- I think the GTR.
- Okay, Riley has a big crush on me.
Let's go.
(engines revving)
- Ready.
Three, two, one.
(screaming)
- Okay that was faster this time Riley.
- Isn't that gnarly.
Good job.
- I wanna do this everyday of my life.
- We almost hit the camera guy.
We almost hit the cop right there.
So you know, Riley took some risks.
I'm the winner of drag racing.
I beat everybody.
I hated every minute of it.
And it's a victory.
And I'm getting an Icee pop as a reward.
At the end of the day it
doesn't matter who won
because we have ice cream.
- Congratulations.
- Yeah that was exhilarating.
100 percent would do it again.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'm proud that I did it twice.
- I think this should be my job now.
I'm gonna change careers.
- I think I've caught the bug now.
I get how people do it
once and they catch the bug
and they wanna keep going.
- Yeah, the next time is to
see how much him and I scream
while you girls are driving.
- Yeah, exactly.
- The next BuzzFeed video for sure.
Screaming girls, drag racing,
iconic location.
One good looking dude and me.
(both laughing)
(upbeat music)